c'est transformer la façon dont nous transformons les organisations
afin que, au lieu d'être épuisant,
cela soit stimulant et énergisant.
Pour cela, il faut nous concentrer sur cinq impératifs stratégiques
qui ont tous une chose en commun :
faire passer les gens d'abord.
Le premier impératif pour faire passer les gens d'abord
est d'inspirer grâce à un objectif.
La plupart des transformations ont des buts financiers et opérationnels.
Ils sont importants et peuvent être énergisants pour les dirigeants
mais ils ont tendance à ne pas motiver la plupart des gens de l'organisation.
Pour motiver à plus grande échelle,
la transformation doit donner un sens plus profond à l'objectif.
Prenez LEGO.
Le groupe LEGO est devenu une entreprise mondiale extraordinaire.
Sous leur direction très compétente,
ils ont traversé une série de transformations.
Bien que chacune de ces transformations avaient un but précis,
l’Étoile du Berger,
les connectant et liant toutes,
a été l'objectif puissant de LEGO :
inspirer et développer les bâtisseurs de demain.
Se développer mondialement ?
Il n'est pas question d'augmenter les ventes,
mais de donner accès à des briques LEGO à des millions d'autres enfants.
Investir et innover ?
Ce ne sont pas de nouveaux produits
mais permettre à plus d'enfants
de ressentir la joie de l'apprentissage par le jeu.
Il n'est pas surprenant
que ce sens d'objectif profond tende à fortement motiver les employés de LEGO.
Le second impératif pour faire passer les gens d'abord
est de tout donner.
Trop de transformations
ne sont rien d'autre qu'un exercice de diminution du personne,
des licenciements déguisés en transformation.
Face à une compétition impitoyable,
il est possible que vous ayez à prendre la difficile décision
de réduire la taille de l'organisation,
tout comme vous devez perdre du poids pour courir un marathon.
La perte de poids seule
ne vous fera pas passer la ligne d'arrivée le premier.
Pour gagner,
il faut tout donner.
Il faut tout donner.
Plutôt que de juste baisser les coûts,
il faut penser à des initiatives
qui vous permettront de gagner à moyen terme,
d'entraîner une croissance,
des actions qui changeront fondamentalement
la façon d'opérer de l'entreprise
et, très important,
les investissements pour développer le leadership et le talent.
Le troisième impératif pour faire passer les gens d'abord
est de permettre aux gens ayant les capacités nécessaires
de réussir durant la transformation et au-delà de celle-ci.
Au fil des ans, j'ai participé à nombre de triathlons.
Franchement, je ne suis pas si bon
mais j'ai une capacité distincte ;
je retrouve très rapidement mon vélo.
(Rires)
Quand je finis la natation,
presque tous les vélos sont déjà partis.
(Rires)
Les vrais triathlètes savent que chaque épreuve --
la nage, le vélo, la course --
requiert des capacités très différentes,
des outils différents,
des compétences différentes, des techniques différentes.
De même, quand nous transformons des organisations,
nous devons nous assurer que nous donner aux gens
les compétences et les outils dont ils ont besoin.
Chronos,
une entreprise mondiale de logiciels,
a reconnu le besoin de passer de la création de produits --
de logiciels --
à la création de logiciels en tant que service.
Pour permettre aux employés de faire cette transformation,
ils ont investi dans de nouveaux outils
qui permettent aux employés de suivre l'utilisation des fonctions
ainsi que la satisfaction des clients quant au nouveau service.
Ils ont aussi investi dans le développement de compétences,
afin que leurs employés puissent
résoudre sur le champ les problèmes de service client.
Très important,
ils ont aussi renforcé les comportements collaboratifs nécessaires
pour fournir une expérience client entièrement intégrée.
Du fait de ces investissements,
plutôt que d'être dépassés par la transformation,
les employés de Chronos se sont sentis motivés
et stimulés par leurs nouveaux rôles.
A l'ère de la transformation constante,
le changement est permanent.
De ce fait, mon quatrième impératif
est d'instiller une culture d'apprentissage permanent.
Quand Satya Nadella est devenu PDG de Microsoft
en février 2014,
il a entrepris une ambitieuse transformation
pour préparer l'entreprise à rivaliser
dans un monde où les téléphones et le cloud sont primordiaux.
Cela incluait des changements dans la stratégie,
l'organisation
et, surtout, la culture.
La culture de Microsoft de l'époque était une de silos, de compétition interne
pas très propice à l'apprentissage.
Nadella a pris le taureau par les cornes.
Il a rallié ses dirigeants autour de sa vision
pour une culture vivante d'apprentissage,
passant d'un état d'esprit fixe
où le rôle était d'apparaître comme la personne la plus intelligente,
à un état d'esprit de croissance
où le rôle est d'écouter, d'apprendre, de faire ressortir le meilleur chez le gens.
Les premiers jours,
les employés de Microsoft ont remarqué ce changement de culture --
une preuve évidente que Microsoft faisait passer les gens d'abord.
Mon cinquième et dernier impératif est spécifique aux dirigeants.
Lors d'une transformation,
un dirigeant doit avoir une vision,
un plan précis avec des étapes
et il faut responsabiliser les gens par rapport aux résultats.
En d'autres mots, il faut être directif.
Mais, afin de conquérir les cœurs et les esprits des gens,
il faut aussi être inclusif.
Le leadership inclusif est crucial pour faire passer les gens d'abord.
Je vis dans la baie de San Francisco.
Actuellement,
notre équipe de basket-ball est la meilleure de la ligue.
Nous avons gagné le championnat de 2015
et nous sommes les favoris cette année.
Il y a beaucoup d'explications à cela.
Ils ont de joueurs fabuleux
mais l'une des raisons principales
est que leur entraîneur principal, Steve Kerr, est un dirigeant inclusif.
Quand Kerr est arrivé chez les Warriors en 2014,
les Warriors voulaient une grande transformation.
Ils n'avaient pas gagné de championnat national depuis 1975.
Kerr est arrivé, il avait une vision claire
et il s'est mis au travail immédiatement.
Dès le début,
il a engagé le dialogue et parlé avec les joueurs et le personnel.
Il a créé un environnement de débat ouvert et a sollicité les suggestions.
En match, il demandait souvent :
« Que voyez-vous qui m'échappe ? »
Un des meilleurs exemples de cela était lors du quatrième match
du championnat de 2015.
Les Warriors étaient menés 2-1
quand Kerr a décidé de changer le 5 de départ.
Une décision audacieuse.
Les Warriors ont gagné le match et ont remporté le championnat.
L'avis général
est que cette décision a servi de pivot vers la victoire.
Il est intéressant de savoir que ce n'était pas l'idée de Kerr.
C'était l'idée de son assistant de 28 ans, Nick U'Ren.
Du fait du style de leadership de Kerr,
U'Ren s'est senti à l'aise pour exprimer son idée.
Kerr n'a pas seulement écouté
mais il a implémenté l'idée
et, après,
a attribué le mérite à U'Ren --
des actions toutes en accord
avec l'approche très inclusive de leadership de Kerr.
Dans une ère de transformation constante,
les organisations seront toujours en transformation.
Mais cela n'a pas à être épuisant.
Nous le devons à nous-mêmes,
à nos organisations
et à la société en général
de transformer audacieusement notre approche de la transformation.
Pour faire cela,
nous devons commencer à faire passer les gens d'abord.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)